Champlain's discoveries could have resulted in an extraordinary new world empire for the French.
Yes, but as we saw, the English Corps of Colonies was destined to become the immense territory of the United States of America.
Despite the raids of the conquistadors, who did manage to go quite a ways,
the Spanish could keep only a small fringe of territory.
You've told us about the French, Spanish, English. What of the Indians?
Yeah, the Indians had come here much earlier. I mean, they could claim it.
That's right, maestro. What's the Indian story?
Who cares about a bunch of Indians?
I mean, it's kind of interesting.
Now that you ask, I'll tell you about the Indians
and what their lives were like in America in this 17th century.
In the southwest near Spanish territories, there lived the Pueblos.
Dole our seas. It's those Apaches again.
Better to cultivate their fields.
And not steal from us.
Ride in.
She a naughty slave.
We'd be able, the two of us, to live in peace with the Sioux where our son was born.
We must go so many years of migration long. We are tired now my children
I understand you have crossed great plains and valleys and mountains an entire continent from sea to shining sea
From sunrise in the east to sunset in the west. I'm a bit closer. You'll be power huttons like us come here now
You needn't fear the Spanish anymore. You'll be just like us near here. There's an English village
Oh, yes, they too wear cloth, and they're not always kind to us when you have rested
I will take you to our great king, Powhatan.
He's very wise, you'll see, and there are 200 villages like this one in his kingdom.
White medicine.
The men wearing cloth first came.
We gave them everything.
They were miserable.
We helped them.
Most of them almost starved to death.
Saved them.
Then, little by little, reinforced, they used their weapons.
They hurt our...
They went into our storehouses and stole our grain rather than work.
Then they took our lands instead of clearing new lands.
If you're as bad as you say, well, why wouldn't you simply destroy them?
Are you not a great chief with many warriors?
No, Powahattans detest any violence.
Before using force, we resort to cunning.
No, Captain John Smith.
I do, Father, and I think the man is handsome.
Then this is the plan we'll use, Pocahontas.
Every day white men cheat. They steal more of our land.
No, we capture them, but everyone alive.
Come, chief of the white men.
You and your brothers have all broken your word, and Chief Powahattan is pained.
so you will die as example.
Die?
Listen.
Well, you can't.
You can.
Pocahontas, your daughter, begs you to pardon him.
Oh, my child, he has betrayed our confidence and must die.
And you swear that in the future they will cheat no more.
Yes, I swear it, and I swear it on my own life.
And you may release him.
I vow your word.
Yes, Pocahontas.
Good, John.
You know, you're a pretty girl.
Of course, the truce didn't last long.
When the English sent people to the colonies,
well, they weren't always their best subjects.
You could expect the worst.
In the third winter in the colonies, people were starving.
It got so bad that finally Captain John Smith forgot all about the promises he had made.
But Shanganu was never to forget this insult.
Now the colonists had made a mortal enemy, and they were to pay very dearly.
Captain John Smith returns to England.
His companions promptly seize the Indian planting fields,
Treating these proud free people as slaves, as, as redskins.
Let's go, let's go faster, bunch of lazy good-for-nothings.
I know what you need.
Come, there's two of you.
I gave him a swig of good old pick-me-up.
If it's really a pick-me-up, you're going to need a whole bottle.
Go on.
Chief Powhatan is dead.
His brother, Opichonkanu, is now the chief.
22nd, 1622 was to be a tragic day.
On that morning, 27 white people die in the St. James River.
The terrible cycle of violence is set off with no holds barred,
but the new governor, Francis Wyatt, is a clever fellow.
He invites the chief and his leaders to a powwow and personally guarantees their safety.
So the war against the Powhatans was to last for 14 years.
But Opechanka knew he could wait 22 years for his revenge.
He was 100 years old.
Now, my sons, we take our revenge at last.
Tomorrow at dawn, we attack Jamestown.
Father, I'm sorry to say it, but I can't do it.
Please forgive me, Father.
For miles around, everybody talked about the Indian victory at Jamestown.
Ten years later, just a few miles to the north,
live the Delaware Indian.
No, don't be afraid.
The Swedish men are always honest.
Or a yellow thing.
You know this money that we use called wampum?
It's difficult to make.
It takes a long time.
But pale-face money is easy to make.
It is?
Careful. Here comes the Iroquois.
But he gave you nothing at all.
He gave us peace. He didn't attack us.
Iroquois are fierce warriors.
Later, this will be called a racket.
Only at this time in history, the word doesn't exist.
Hey, Pop, we be Iroquois.
1654, the Swedes buy Delaware and the Hinta Regents from the Indians.
Paying for it with guns and ammunition.
But they were able to keep it only one year.
So be all right for this time, but next time I want guns or skins.
Why? Tell me why.
The Dutch give us one rifle for every ten skins.
They chase the Swedes out.
They bring much wampum from their homeland.
Dutch aren't friendly the way Swedes are.
Be careful. We're with them.
What is it?
Koi.
Let's go.
They're not among our friends, but you can stay with us until you find your people again.
We're doing an Iroquois territory.
But they all...
Don't stay here. The English and the Dutch pay well for every Algonquin scalp.
Adirakoi.
Is he holding there a weapon, is it?
Looks more like a sort of scalp.
No, it's like a feather headdress.
And just what are you people doing here?
We've followed the coast several moons now.
Come with me. I am Wampanooga.
I will take you to see our King Philip.
You see, I am his royal interpreter. This way.
You are welcome. We are all glad to see you, and you gladden our hearts.
There are great events soon to come.
Now, come. I will show you the people of my tribe.
There are more and more white people here, always with more weapons, and ever more greedy.
Our only chance of survival is to join forces against them.
Philip is summoned to Plymouth by the Puritan leaders.
Soon he realizes that he has been betrayed by his interpreter.
They impose unacceptable conditions.
According to the terms, Philip is to deliver all his tribe's firearms.
Most of the leaders refuse.
That was the end of the traitor.
You belong to us.
Speak to me.
subject of your English king I don't speak to subjects no his majesty the king to him I will
speak I'm even looking forward to it right idea we'll get one for all Algonquin's escaped that
night the English pay a high price for Algonquin scalps not too tight old friend I can't breathe
well you know what they say Iroquois are the strongest Iroquois are the strongest how come
I'm not an Iroquois deacons foreigners war makes our young warriors strong and body and mind
What are you going to do to them?
The men and children will take them into our tribe.
What about the men?
Can't say yet.
First, they'll have to pass tests.
Depending on how they do, they could come into the tribe.
Or they're killed.
Depends on how they do.
Look, the great council of the tribes of five nations will begin soon.
A great and powerful country, France, is offended by all these wars
that the Iroquois people are waging against our friends.
Not to mention the harm you are causing to offer collecting.
If you agree to live in peace, you will be rewarded.
Yes, but the minute you break the peace, we'll reply with new weapons that are so terrible you'll regret it.
In the end, the story is always the same. White men speak with forked tongue. Words last very few moons.
Here we are on our own land, and we're all of us united.
If your warriors come and dig up the hatchet and cut down the tree of peace,
they will find a great Iroquois nation ready and willing to defend itself.
They're for medicine men.
Only those initiated in false face rituals wear masks like this.
It's true we Indians like to fight.
And because of that, the Pale Faces put one tribe against another purposely to get what they want.
They play with us, like children.
And yet those first Englishmen at Jamestown wouldn't have survived without Powahattans.
They hunted them down and exterminated them.
All the Powahattans.
They completely massacred King Philip's whole tribe.
and yet those greedy Puritans would all have starved to death
if the Indian tribes hadn't helped them.
They wiped out the Mohegans who were allies.
Same with the Delawares.
Same story with so many others.
Gone. All but us.
But why are they evil? They're people like us.
Are they really like us?
They were greedy men, surely, and some were after furs.
Others are hunting grounds, our lands.
Why were they like us?
I wanted to find out if an Indian baby could swim instinctively like a dog.
See, a while back, the French governor, François Deneuville, invited 60 of our men to a banquet.
Better to surprise them.
That's why we have to be the smartest, the strongest, the cleverest.
We must play on the palefaces' rivalry, not the other way around.
Are white men really all like that?
I'm told in Pennsylvania, paleface William Penn is loyal to the Indians, treats them fairly.
I don't know how long that will go on.
Anyway, I don't trust any of those white creatures.
He reminds me of somebody I wonder whom.
That old boy was plenty wise because, well, a few decades later, William Penn's son didn't
hesitate to use any methods to rob the Indians and push them farther and farther away.
Well, that's what I wanted to tell you about the Indians and what it was like back then.